also making a trip to Vegas the
Kardashians who were here last night for
Jimmy Kimmel Live
yeah and that's where Jimmy went there I
mean he went there with Khloe
I do want to ask about this character
that you had a baby with Oh me yeah oh
yeah is it time to stop dating
basketball players I like what I like
what can I say yeah Keltie night was
keeping up with a Kim today to talk
about all the latest family drama do you
think Jimmy went too far no I
he's always funny thought it was fine
while Khloe's called it quits with baby
daddy Tristan Thompson all the drama
will unfold in the new season of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians do you think
there can be forgiveness I think
boundaries are good lessons are good
forgiveness is good but you really have
to talk to the people who are a little
more involved there's also a lot of joy
Kim and Kanye have baby number four on
the way a little boy be a surrogate last
time we sat down you had mentioned that
the thing that really stressed you out
about surrogacy was like the lack of
control it's definitely a harder
experience than I anticipated
is it different this time it's a
different experience for sure I think
every situation is different I love my
surrogate we have a really good
relationship I feel really calm and at
ease now the busy moms getting into the
shade business partnering with eyewear
company Karolina Lemke the Kim
kardashian-west collection launches
today so we have over 20 styles that are
gonna be launching before summer and I
got so into it that I just I couldn't
choose so we are gonna play a game of
Shady
not Shady with Kim Kardashian we'll
leave our shades on if it's Shady and
we'll let look down if it's not staying
in touch with an X when you're in a new
relationship depends on how it ended
exactly yeah is that like a
dishing about your sex life with your
girlfriends oh my god of course I could
take those all the way before that one
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]